foreign
the videos with friends not like you
should do this but like it's amazing how
timely it will be like like my friend
who had kidney stones recently and like
you shared a video a few weeks ago about
oxalates or whatever and I'm like oh
you'll you'll find Value in this video
and we tend to share things when we find
Value in it and I find immense value in
what you're putting out there and so big
thanks for that you're welcome thank you
and I want to say that one of the things
you said recently on there you said the
worst most addictive food to eat is what
french fries
chocolate bacon french fries you're
gonna have to leave
yeah that that got a lot of Engagement
we're gonna have to talk about that more
but basically you take there are actual
published studies looking at products of
breakdown of linoleic acid most notably
a compound called hne4hne four
hydroxynoninol in French fries and it's
off the charts and that compound at
least in animal models and a clearly in
human uh trials as well appears to just
completely sabotage our satiety
mechanisms now you're talking about
French fries like you go to McDonald's
you get the french fries like because
they're so processed and what they're
fried in or like can you still can you
do like a potato and like maybe fry it
up like you know cut it up and then fry
it up in some Tallow I think it would be
much better in Tallow you'd have much
lower levels of hne but you know we went
to we went to a Burger Joint here in
town that's super popular and we asked
them and they fry in I think it's
sunflower oil or something maybe peanut
oil uh one of the two it could have been
peanut oil but they again like a lot of
these places will tout that they're
heart healthy oils with peanut oil acid
and french fries have hugely high
amounts of hne and then you see you take
something like a potato which is a
starch and there are studies that show
that potatoes by themselves high in
oxalates not a huge fan of them in
general but they're a very satisfying
food right you take a potato and you fry
it in a highly polyunsaturated oil like
linoleic acid seed oil hne goes through
the roof because the breakdown products
fascinating you're hungry you can't stop
eating it yeah but it sounds like you're
saying cooking in an animal fat doesn't
let us off the hook it's still no it
would be much better it would be much
better so if you're cooking it I'm deep
frying is probably not a good thing in
general right you take Tallow and you
absolutely boil it and deep fry it it's
not great but it's going to be way
better than the seed oil like if you
want it to eat a potato a fried potato
it's cooking in Tallow like McDonald's
used to more on the damage that fries do
though more on that yeah uh I mean I
think it's mostly the hne and you're
getting seed oils in the fries and that
that seed oil is very oxidized and then
if you want to get really granular those
potatoes are high in oxalates so you're
getting oxalates you're getting hne
you're getting seed oils you're getting
all kinds of problems so I won't eat
them for myself but I'll give them to
Josh before we play basketball
then he'll get a sunburn if you're
playing out at the beach
did you enjoy this Standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalists private
podcasts available exclusively on
patreon visit patreon.com the
minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free